[Music]
welcome to the session on cloud
automation for industry 4.0 my name is
Eva Durand I'm a product obsolete for
cloud I Amir engineering team in Munich
one of Google's primary goals is to
democratize AI and automation they make
it easy and accessible for all
industries our vision is to harness the
power of AI for the industry across
multiple verticals retail logistics
manufacturing automotive and many others
however before we deep dive into that
vision I want to get us started by
looking at the state of the automation
today automation today is only
economical at scale the upfront costs of
integration are huge and the results are
inflexible to changes in workflows
however there is a new trend emerging on
the market a new generation of
collaborative robots are making the
automation much more affordable they are
equipped with modern sensors and
software layers that are easy to program
this new generation of robots are useful
in unpredictable environments earned
work side by side with humans we still
have to tackle a couple of challenges
before we can leverage the benefits of
that new technology firstly the setup
and maintenance of robot fleets today is
typically brought to the market by
system integrators that create highly
customized solution to individual
clients as a result only
industrial customers can afford
automation and then mostly only for
highly repetitive tasks secondly given
this highly customized nature of
integration
there is a strong vendor lock-in if you
want to renew your lab robot fleet or
use different type of robots setup and
maintenance becomes extremely complex
thirdly most of the assets used for
automation use-cases are proprietary
thus it is hard for both software
developers and hardware manufacturers to
scale the applications and as a result
they are forced to deploy bespoke
solutions for individual clients last
but not least most of the solutions are
deployed only on premise which hinders
scalability flexibility and efficiency
at Google cloud we are dedicated to
handles those challenges in order to
make automation easier and more
affordable our cloud automation platform
provides foundational capabilities for
cloud enabled automation solutions that
are scalable support large data volumes
and speed flexible allowing flexible
distribution and deployment of software
assets and efficient permit better
utilization and infrastructure as a
software provisioning
our cloud optimation solution allows
companies that are interested in the
promise of industry 4.0 to turn the
operations into the competitive
advantage and the key word here is
flexibility that is the ability to
easily connect and operate the fleet
independently of the vendor one key
technology behind that is kubernetes
which builds on years of experience of
Google in automatic deploying and
scaling software assets we also address
fundamental security concepts such as
authentication and authorization we also
facilitate reliable connectivity and
communication with synchronous and
unsecure honest communication and last
but not least we provide critical
infrastructure for sensor data
aggregation and processing that builds
on familiar technologies such as
BigTable bigquery and dataflow as
mentioned the key technology behind that
is kubernetes using kubernetes we
enabled the distribution of
containerized software assets that can
run on three tiers on robot on premise
and in the cloud we use kubernetes to
enable robot hardware abstraction and
command and control that is tolerant to
intermittent connectivity with
kubernetes technology we also create the
opportunity for third-party developers
to quickly engage with our platform and
develop on that
on top of that we want to enable the
vision of what we started calling
digital tween this is the mirror of the
physical world in the digital world
imagine the robot running through that
warehouse and collecting the data on
inventory levels exactly the same robot
can run through that warehouse and flag
damaged items creating new opportunities
for quality management and inventory
zation that is digital tween and AI
capabilities with perception driven
capabilities open the whole set of new
opportunities that go much beyond
automation last but not least on top of
this all this critical infrastructure we
want to offer first party services that
leverage cloud automation platform and
solve critical pain points for for the
clients
the first one is localization and
mapping that uses data from sensors like
lighters and depth cameras it allows
robots to create a map localize
themselves on that map and recognize
static landmarks with our spatial
intelligence service we further want to
analyze that sensor data and
semantically understand the environment
direct robots to ROS shelves instead of
just metric coordinates last but not
least with our object intelligence
service we can use the same data to
discover and
identify important objects in their
location in the workspace that allows
two robots to perform certain operations
on those items so how does all that look
in action the best early implementation
of that technology is best logistics
that's where we work with Bechtler ASAP
as a provider of warehouse management
system Mir mobile industrial robots the
provider of hardware love robot fleet
and novice the enabler of the digital
tween but before I talk too much about
beste I just want to invite vested
cellphone state
Klaus Kratz the head of logistics of
Bachelor to tell tell you about his
experience and how we are making the
impact with our technology okay welcome
thank you very much thank you if I think
you very much for the introduction and
having me I mean that very happy to be
in San Francisco as you have mentioned
we are from Germany and Germany is the
country of the fingers and the poets so
why I should be here and this incredible
innovative place because I have taken I
have adapt your mentality your spirit
the American spirit just to do whatever
it takes to gain new knowledge and new
competences also that's why I'm very
enthusiastic to have started this
project with Google who is novice s IP
and miR a pastor this is our headquarter
at Bethel I'm responsible for logistics
we sell hardware software IT solutions
and IT services of course
cloud services we are a year
peon company and we have partners all
over the world
for example PC connection and
Massachusetts as a partner for us in
America we have more than 10,000
employees and 17,000 happy customers
Voeckler
is in my opinion a German success story
not at the scale of Google of course but
we have tripled our revenues within the
last 10 years from 4.2 billion euro to
from 1.8 billion euro to 4.2 billion
euro and our target is for the next 10
years to double again this turnover to
10 billion euro to reach this target we
have to integrate our customers more
deeply increase in efficiency
flexibility and quality within our
processes and systems and find ways to
cooperate with future strategic partners
when the wind of change blows some
people they build walls others they will
burn mills and we are building windmills
so basically logistic has to change from
volume distribution to a solution
distribution on this way we already
provide where you added services such as
individual taking packaging repackaging
and transporting and also sustain real
solution maybe in the near future we
will have a flat rate for workplace for
all IT equipment and software a customer
needs including recycling and disposal
of used hardware currently we have four
main warehouses the biggest warehouses
in Germany we have our warehouses in
France Switzerland and Netherlands in
the past we had to optimize and
physically alter our warehouses which
require a lot of time and improvisation
skills and a lot of money as you can see
within the next photos and this is
really reality so why we have this
drilling machine in our warehouse
because we had to implement a mezzanine
within our warehouse and we had to drill
30 holes 11 meter deep and this is
really logistic things yeah it's really
tough and we have done like crystal
every night we have covered our Powerex
to avoid dust or our articles and then
you can see the mezzanine it's three and
a half thousand square meters you see
the the white white ellipse behind this
there there are people working and an
American colleague said to me always is
very bad because it's against work
security restrictions so I have hided
these two people there but you can see a
stage a mezzanine is growing and this is
the actual warehouse and the rack we
have big parts like how like servers PCs
notebooks and in the on the on the
mezzanine we have small parts like
cables and USB sticks in the future we
will need many more warehouses in
Germany and also in Europe with a
possibility to automate processes adapt
them to customer requirements we need in
the future very high flexibility dynamic
scalability and very short throughputs
to deliver to our customer as fast as
possible our customers can count on us
for the support they need to reach their
own targets as a transition to German
industry 4.0 the future warehouse in my
opinion is a combination of traditional
technologies like high rec warehouse
systems and modern technologies or new
technologies like autonomous mobile
robots in our warehouse as if I have
said we have already implemented the
Google s IP mere novice solution we are
using the solution for tasks such as
cross docking items cross docking items
means that in inbound logistics we get
the information from s AP
that customer orders have already been
placed for these items instead of
processing put away and picking we bring
these items directly to the outbound
logistics in the past we did this with
electrical vehicles on a pallet and now
we are doing it with Rex multi-level Rex
and the robotics and how its work
working I would show on a video so this
is Claudio the mere robot it's Klaudia
one with the support of its sensors
cloudy picks up the card on which across
stopping items
Claudia starts to drive Ottoman
autonomously to a static native
destination and Claudio drives within a
different zone and avoids barriers that
may occur on its way dependently by
going around them
Claudia observes the environment still
our people have got to get too used to
it in some critical areas with cross
traffic or forklifts Claudius emitting
sounds to get the attention Claudio
transports the car to its designated
destination and moves out for new tasks
yeah it's great and this is a great team
of from Google s AP and Bachelor as a
result of using autonomous mobile robots
and future optimization we can achieve
flexible automation process optimization
scalability and productivity and yeah I
have a good I had a good example from a
forklift driver because we are very
transparent and if we change to such new
technologies we are having an open
communication we speak with our people
and to persuade them because we have an
unemployment rate of 2% in the region
I'm working so we have to be forced to
automate optimize our warehouses because
we don't get any more people we have to
qualify them and so the people have
realized that this is possible and they
are not afraid and the forklift driver
the next day I have mentioned that we go
in this strategy he said to me but mr.
Kutz we you have to pay attention with
the robotics because I don't want to
crash him so people immediately think
about and this is great in my opinion
think immediately what will happen with
these new technologies and this is also
the adaption of the people for these new
technologies so thank you very much for
your attention and if you are ever in
Germany feel free to come by and say
hello
thank you very much Klaus for bringing
your volu perspective to that audience
and sharing your experiences with our
project just thank you we'll continue
this is exactly the best implementation
of how we and our partners such as mere
novice and si pecan men make an impact
for businesses like best law in
particular we need to make sure that we
make automation drastically simpler and
less expensive our core value
proposition does has to be flexible
automation with collaborative robots
that can seamlessly and gradually be
deployed into the existing environment
as needed secondly we need to escape the
vendor lock-in trap and enable an easy
deployment of heterogeneous fleet that
our vendor agnostic clients like
bestseller shouldn't have to take care
of coordinating the robots and processes
between different kind of robots rather
we should enable an ear earpieces than
the assignment of tasks and orders in an
intelligent manner across various robots
thirdly we now have a chance to grow our
impact by shaping new opportunities in
analytics for example quality management
inventory zation space management and so
on so forth by putting our AI
capabilities into action will enable the
vision of digital twin generating new
insights that go much beyond pure
automation finally we need to break away
from purely on print solutions that are
difficult to scale and suffer from
limited flexibility and low resource
utilization rather cloud automation
should use kubernetes to enable easy
deployment and distribution of container
right software assets that can run on
robot on premise and in the cloud with
all that we can generate real business
impact that allows fast and easy
automation and enables the flexibility
in setting up and maintaining automation
processes it facilitates efficiency and
increased utilization by efficient fleet
management better and faster
localization and optimized path planning
it also triggers productivity
improvements by turning analytics into
action and opening new opportunities in
inventory space and quality management
and last but not least it provides bases
for scalability competitiveness and
better customer service that will allow
businesses to reap new revenue sources
and engage with new clients but to
enable all that vision and leverage
technology we need to work with our
partners and grow that platform into an
ecosystem where each of the participants
can benefit and contribute providing the
complimentary skills that's why we
invited some of them today to share
their experiences with cloud automation
platform and explain to you how we can
all create our new business
opportunities for them and on that note
I want to invite some stage our partners
nemrut diversion Oh head of industry 4.0
at sa P he leads innovation projects in
the areas of logistics manufacturing and
retail and drives programs for the
intelligent enterprise strategy for sa p
thank you very much for being here
welcome stage we also have Niels
Jacobson co-founder and CEO of Mir
mobile industrial robots one of the
largest collaborative robotics
manufacturers in the world thank you for
coming then we have Farex Rhines Hardin
co-founder and CEO of novice a powerful
platform for the digital twin for in
their applications thank you very much
for flying over to San Francisco and
last but not least we have Moritz
Tanner's CTO of magazine o that builds
and developed intelligence collaborative
robots for internal districts with
particular focus on mobile picking
robots thank you very much
we had one turd things you guys hope you
have good trip thanks for coming here
and sharing your experiences to that
audience
on the cloud automation platform I want
to get us started by by asking you a
question the same question to all of you
please explain how how are your
companies benefiting from from the cloud
automation platform what are the key
challenges that you are facing at this
stage and what are the benefits that you
are drawing from working together in
that ecosystem and maybe let's let's get
us started with mirror getting from from
the bottom of the stack from the
hardware okay I can say that at Mia we
develop and manufacture what we call
autonomous mobile robots or AMR and we
do that for indoor transportation to
help the logistic there to optimize
logistic and also as we heard before
actually to free some of the working
force there so some of the challenge
since we see there as you have already
mentioned actually is this the cost of
integration we are distributing all our
robots through a network of integrators
and and they are taking the robots to
the end-users integrating that for that
purpose and it still takes a lot of time
and is costly even though we have a
simple system to operate on there and
then you can also say that sometimes
that the customer they always are new
new way of using the robots that they
would like and that's always something
that we you not can provide out of the
box then the customer has to wait either
for a software upgrade from our side or
find another solution for that and then
we have the last module science is the
integration with a ERP or warehouse
management system there we also see that
that tends to be a lot of specialized
software there and here we really see
that that this cloud solution can't go
in and and help us on many of the points
there this ability to to have versioning
and updating the system Mallis for free
now we also see that with a cloud
platform where the ability to have data
aggregated to the cloud in a way that
you can do analyze this is now possible
on a much larger scale and also the
ability to to have adding clocks like an
SI p integration there can be of great
help for us he mentioned s AP and the
integration with
yura pieces tum' what is sa piece saying
on that what are the kill challenges
that you are facing and building on that
point exactly how are we benefiting from
working with with us and with with Niels
and all the other partners Rudy yeah the
thing is that s appears a lot of
customers not only in warehouse
management environment and more and more
of our customers are interested in
making use of collaborative robots and
the thing is usually also our customers
have different kind of specific
processes they want to have being
customized depending on which areas they
are like mining manufacturing discrete
and process industries or logistics the
thing of course is that looking at those
devices those robots they have different
kind of capabilities compared to static
robots that are they can be trained they
can repeat their their processes over
and over again why you have seen it on
the pictures on the on video that they
have more capabilities more dynamic
features that need to be considered so
in our case we cannot really cover
everything and therefore we need a kind
of a flexible environment where we can
also integrate customers partners and
third-party solutions easily and that's
what the cloud robotics platform will
help us to cope with all kind of
challenges that are related to
collaborative robots in this case just
as an example if glass is going to make
use of further fleets that are not from
here or from from magazine o then the
challenge will be to orchestrate them
okay and orchestrate dream is one thing
but to assign the task from the backend
accordingly will be the next thing so
but to do it over and over again for
every customer would not make sense at
all so we will be definitely benefiting
from this cloud robotics initiative to
plug in existing solutions even custom
develop solutions for specific customers
and we can deploy them easily regardless
if that component is being deployed on
robot and a cloud on Prem depending on
the user
of course and then we will be definitely
be more flexible than we were in the
past to integrate all kind of devices
building on the point of both Niels and
Rudy mentioned cloud Felix you are
gathering with enabler of the digital
tween a lot of data
how are you benefiting from the cloud
and from from the cloud automation
platform at this stage
permit me say a few words on what we are
doing at Navis be cursus whole term of
digital twin is gaining a lot of
momentum and I think it still needs a
little bit of explanation so what we are
doing is we do not model environment but
we scan environment and we scan it on
mobile devices think about the mini
version of the famous Google car now
capable of working without GPS and
equipped with scanners with cameras and
it creates super dense and detailed 3d
maps of its environment that we then
overlay was more information and make
walkable digital twins out of that that
you can access in your browser and
that's the point today we are creating
already digital twins of manufacturing
facilities for a lot of the largest
automotive companies in the world but
the data is being created and and
process in a form that its most catering
towards human beings for space
optimization logistics optimization
however of course we want to make this
data accessible for our clients in a
much more flexible way and we believe
that in the future this data will be
perhaps even be used by more robot than
human beings and and man all the points
come into play that you mentioned before
there will be very different kinds of
robots and they all need to be capable
of accessing not only our data but
potentially as well as a model data so
at the end we need good automation we
need standardized interfaces that allow
for a variety of different robots as
well as software solutions to make use
of this data that will make our clients
happy and of course will drive the
adoption of what we are doing so that's
why we're here
yeah and building on that more it's
you're not only building hardware but
also software what are the key
challenges that you're facing and how
it's called
how can you we do that you know so with
our company we're building the hardware
but especially all the software and the
cloud it equation for mobile robots that
not only navigate and transport but also
pick and they these robots can operate
alongside the humans in the same
environment so they can drive through
the warehouses identify the items pick
from the shelves cannot go into the
shelves and basically do all of this in
a shared environment with humans that
pick the same items from the same
shelves and so on and especially this
collaboration with humans creates lots
of challenges because humans changed the
words and compared to classical robots
that really liked it when everything is
deterministic and predefined we live in
a pretty uncertain world
we're still in a warehouse we're not in
the children's room and in the afternoon
that is much more uncertain probably but
the word is changing constantly and the
big challenge is how do you on the one
hand design software that is scale
scalable that is capable of analyzing
this data that is can perceive the world
and derive the right actions from that
how do you develop and deploy this
software to a fleet of robots that are
somewhere in the warehouses but the big
challenge I think that we're sharing
with other people dealing with
autonomous robots especially how to make
them go bust so how to make it resilient
to change as two inch perturbations to
all kinds of kinds of changes that
others have to cope with and that's a
pretty data-driven thing so the
developers don't sit next to the robots
they don't see what happened so you
really need to transfer all this this
context all this information from the
robots to the developers or to your
machine learning algorithms and that's
something where we can really benefit
from the cloud I think on the one hand
for using computation in the cloud on
the other hand also for using data
storage so how can we stream the data
I'm going to make it available for easy
debugging also make it available for
automated machine learning on that and
another track is definitely how can we
use cloud technology in order to deploy
software on the robots on the on-premise
service and the cloud service and for
example with the cloud engine how
deploy applications on all of these
different layers at the same time how do
we roll it back and souls so that's
super useful first and that's that
definitely to keep and coming back to
the hardware once more news how do you
see the future for collaborative
robotics and how this open platform and
open echo system can help you grow the
market in the future you can say in a
way we we've already seen with our
mobile robot that there's a whole
community now building what we call
chopped modules so that is different
platforms you put on troubled robots and
and that is already striving yeah and
but but it's still limited in a way
because we cannot add new software to it
in an easy way so it's my hope that we
in this way can envision actually is
becoming a community that can provide
new solutions for us not only on
hardware but also the capability of
moving the robot in another way we can
have someone following people knowing
what to do and this can actually be a
kind of business where this software
companies that are living from just
creating this additional tool set for
four different kind of vendors there we
see that as really a kind of hope for
that because we have many ones today
that want to build more really good
solutions but are just too small
companies for that because this is to
spread then you also see this ability to
move a lot of the computing from the
robots into the cloud something we have
been hoping for more than 10 years but
now we think that the foundation there
is more or less ready so so we can see
the first thing there things like
planning how the robots is moving from
in the warehouse there of course the
robe on their own can do that but now we
have several hundreds of robot moving
together how this orchestration as we
talked before how that can be done that
just
make a demand for much more computing
power that shouldn't be on the robot
there but should be on some kind of
cloud computing platform there and and
last I think we just released our first
AR product this week so AI is really
coming on to the robots there but you
see much more of that
this is really a field that's moving
very very fast and I don't think any
wenda can sit down and say we can do it
the best we need to be open and see what
others can come up with there and we
really feel and also some of the things
you have presented this week here that
these are really really good platforms
on how the robots can learn to interact
much more with the people so we really
hope that the robotics platform will be
the distribution of new services new
applications moretz you mentioned you
are building a lot of software for for
your about sorry for your for your
hardware how would that help you in the
Ponemon and distribution is that the
kubernetes so kubernetes at the
different layers we really promises to
facilitate the soul the whole DevOps
tasks and yet you have to do on many
robots that are in the fields with
different Internet connectivity levers
also having to someone from its
installation some cloud installations
and so on and that can be put in
challenging if you have large fleets
also different hardware so I mean it's
not all virtualized you really have
physical devices behind that that's
mechanically different there and really
deploying to these things managing them
having the fleets and data management I
think that is one big thing that we can
benefit from another one is we really
use the cloud capabilities for making
these robots more intelligent more
robust so doing more machine learning in
the cloud but also using existing
services from the cloud and integrating
them more easily and I think the third
part is what's also planned for the
robotics platform to have the
marketplace so that we can benefit from
other people's components for example
the localization component also some may
be some image recognition
parts that we can also use it for
sharing our own applications with others
so if other Robert vendors can use
certain control components for example
that we have a way of sharing that and
also sharing the experiences we made
there on solving this we world problems
and building on the application
marketplace what are the benefits in the
future for youth Alex and for novice as
you engage on that marketplace and in
the article system so just to give you
an impression on you know what we create
it's layers and layers of data
it starts was really the replication of
the physical reality in point clouds and
images that then transformed into 3d
models and each step is kind of a data
refinery you know puts layers and layers
of data like you start with the with the
raw oil and end up with all the
different plastics products and of
course on all these different stages you
have very complex processing a lot of
machine learning and I a lot of that we
do ourselves but you are spreading
yourself is very thin if you're trying
to do all of that yourself and as well
all these kind of intermediate products
are as well very important raw materials
so to say for a lot of other
applications and on all these different
layers you account at the problem of
generalizations and interfacing and of
course we are talking about vast amounts
of data we are now scanning tens of
millions of square feet of data every
single months some of bark lines with
hundreds of millions of square foot of
industrial space now move from scanning
perhaps once every six months to every
month and in the future one to scan
every day so they want to have something
like a real time to share twin only a
very scalable and robust cloud platform
can actually handle this kind of data
run continuous leads through all these
kind of stages of data processing so
it's a matter of scalability absolutely
it's a matter of interoperability with
all the different players and of course
I think at the end you need a
marketplace because it will be myriad of
different applications that do this data
refinement in as well
kind of take their data and
on each of the layers between different
applications so yeah I think that is why
we believe that kind of cloud or kind of
large-scale
automated robotic platforms will play
such an important role for us and I
think it's not even possible to move
that kind of ecosystem forward without
Trudy maybe in building on that point of
creating the marketplace and leveraging
different applications for the for the
business processes
how is ERP system and SCP dealing with
that and benefiting from that and also
ICP and Google have a broader strategic
partnership so how does this project
fits into the overall relationship and
partnership between Google and and ICP
maybe you can comment on that I think
this project has already proven that the
combined set up having Google as a kind
of infrastructure provider to us in this
robotics project and us being able to
concentrate on the business processes
only allowed us then indeed to you know
to ignore all this communication data
storage and data management device
management stuff that all of you need of
course Nick would need to take care of
but it allowed us to concentrate to keep
the core focus on the improvements of
things that you want to extend in our
case to get the warehouse management
being connected to the robots very
easily and that we can use
infrastructures that are easy to
integrate to also to deploy the
different components and containers very
easily and that we can identify easily
which components to use for the specific
use cases this allows us of course on
our journey to support our customers
regarding the intelligent enterprises
that most of our customers are up to
also to include further
capabilities that the Google cloud that
will outperform is providing as you
could see on the videos for example the
machine learning based vision service
that Google is providing that we can
integrate easily into scenarios and use
cases easily without having two weeks or
two months of custom development that
will definitely be a very big benefit to
many of our customers if they want
through it we include and enhance their
processes and usually any customer that
we have is somehow interested in
integrating more and more of the AI and
ml capabilities so at the moment we can
start with the foundation that we have
first that we have already in place but
depending on the use case that the
customer is interested in we can pick
different components that are for
example on the cloud platform or a
customer or or even our partner is
providing and integrate it into the
intuitive process very easily and
compared to former times it is by far by
far more easier now to do so and
especially also in conjunction with the
industry for Oh initiative in in Germany
that I'm also driving our goal is to
have an environment where we can do a
plug and play of devices of robots that
our customers can easily integrate the
devices in your process in your business
but also make use of intelligent
services that can be coming of course
from Google from the Google cloud
platform but also from embedded business
applications that we already have in
place so therefore it is definitely our
complimentary set up to enable our
customers accomplishing the goal to have
an intelligent enterprise in the near
future and as well on that positive note
benefiting from from the partnership
reverse ap with the business knowledge
and b2b application so I think we all
can benefit from that and
since we are running out of time I don't
think there is a better way to end that
panel just by saying that we as Google
are only as successful as our partners
are so we we are happy that you are
happy so to speak and for our clients
like best we definitely want to drive
business impact drive efficiency
scalability flexibility for our partners
whether there are startups developers
ERP providers and so on and so forth
we definitely want to enable new
business opportunities and enable you to
to reap new revenue sources and grow the
market reach so that's our common goal I
think for all of us so on that positive
note thank you very much for your
attention and feel free to reach out to
us after this session if you have any
questions thank you
[Applause]
[Music]